it's my first award show ever yeah so
that's I'm very excited I'm so excited I
have the hottest date in the world so I
I can't get back any better than this
and it's my first time seeing Harry
Styles live and I'm with a very seasoned
Harry Styles veteran I mean that's my
daddy right there I feel like I've got
the best date in the place yeah yeah the
performance we're most looking forward
to is Harry Styles yes or Brandy
Carlisle or lizzo or like it's it's
impossible to pick there are so many
amazing artists performing tonight and I
can't wait so how
what part are we going to party tonight
it is Friday night I mean I didn't
schedule anything till like 1pm tomorrow
so I'm gonna have a good time yeah I
mean I'm a sober girly but I still go
hard with um my mind so and Chris is on
New York Times so we're gonna get to him
to bed yes yes I'm gonna go to bed but
I'm also gonna live it up I'm gonna do
the both are you most excited to bring
coffee to the tonight oh
um well I don't know whoever will take
it no but I have you know it's there's
so many wonderful artists here so many
people who I've maybe met once or twice
that I feel like I would love to be able
to get bring coffee to at some point
it's a long day but they need caffeine
yeah right I'm just trying to support
art you know
yeah one of your best friends Meghan
Trainor having a baby having a baby
she's incredible we're so excited for
her welcome another little Riley oh my
gosh I mean it's just gonna be I can't I
cannot wait to for there to be two of
them in the world wow how fun
thank you Christian siriano thank you so
much Christian
um and Brad gareski dressed me tonight
and it I just felt like a princess it
feels very like 2023 Audrey Hepburn and
I feel like honestly like I'm stepping
into my Womanhood in a really exciting
way so I'm excited to show something a
little sexier you know special to be
here tonight
I can't imagine being here any other way
and I'm just so grateful that the
Universe kind of let me find that
identity before thrusting me into this
world and now the world gets to meet me
in my true self so and it's we're on Day
2 29 of girlhood today so 329 we're
almost to 365. oh that's right it's
coming out it's coming up get ready
in a big way and there might be some
singing it might be in a big city it
might be very glam
I'll you'll know soon
oh are we mentally preparing what city
I'm so I've I've entered myself for the
lottery I don't know if I got in would I
know but I think we're gonna who are we
gonna call I'm gonna I gotta make sure
I'm there somehow I will work my way
into there I'll do I'll I'll work the
doors or whatever like you know yeah let
me yes exactly I'll have a coffee bar
yeah that's a good way in yes right I'll
have to figure something else no no yeah
[Music]
foreign